[Musique]
oh regardez bien sa tête il faisait bien
sa tête
regardez bien ce statut n'a pas boosté
par terre regardez bien il a tabassé par
terre
[Musique]
le patron hier soir et m'envoie un
message tu veux aller bouffer tu es plus
fort que c'est pour ça que je t'aide
auprès de moi je suis à vtélé cela etc
on attend le monde doit changer ça donc
ce n'est pas trop mon soutien à mes j'ai
plus connus finnair
[Musique]
on
en
nous savons aujourd'hui que monsieur
benalla à utiliser presque une vingtaine
de fois ces passeports entre le 1er août
2010 8 et le 31 décembre et la première
utilisation et du 1er août au 7 août
donc je vous le réaffirme solennellement
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
co-rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je ne vous ai pas menti le 19 septembre
lorsque je vous ai dit que mes passeport
était à l'elysée et ses passeports ont
été rendus à nouveau alors que j'avais
été contacté par un membre de l'elysée
un personnel salarié de l'elysée début
octobre 2018
ils m'ont été restitués comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure avec un certain
nombre d'éléments personnels un chéquier
une perte de clés dans des conditions
qui sont celles qu'elles ont été
quand on a lu ce document
bien évidemment on a demandé au chef de
cabinet et c'est lui qui avait adressé
ce document au ministère de l'intérieur
et il n'est pas l'auteur de cette note
donc soupçonnant une falsification faite
par monsieur benalla nous avons signalé
ce fait au procureur de la république à
un article 40
[Musique]
vous